in this video we're going to be using L
systems or Lindenmayer systems for
procedural plant generation some quick
background L systems or Lindenmayer
systems have been around for a long time
they were originally devised by our
estate Lyndon Mayer a Hungarian
theoretical biologist and botanist and
he was using them at least initially to
describe the development of simple
multicellular organisms later on the
system was extend to describe more
complex branching structures like plants
so that's interesting but what exactly
is an L system basically they're like a
set of symbols and rules and you
iteratively apply those rules over and
over again getting a larger set of
symbols which you then in turn convert
into geometric structure if that sounds
like just a pile of words let's go over
this bit by bit there are a few
definitions you need to start with the
alphabet which is the set of symbols
that we're using the axiom which is just
a fancy word for the set of starting
symbols or like the initial state and
then there are the rules which you apply
to create more simple so let's walk
through an example using our own symbols
we're gonna start with these two symbols
F and R which stand for forward and
right and forward in this example means
move forward a little bit draw a line
from the start and end point and right
means turn right in this example it
literally just means turn right and so
starting with the axiom F R and with the
rules that F turns into F are F so
starting with FR FR turns into f r FR
because f substitutes with Fr F and then
FR FR turns into FR FR FR FR and as you
can see as we drew along with this the
final example was a square so you might
be able to make out from this that
there's a recursive nature to l-systems
and that as you iterate and replace
parts of the string a lot of
self-similarity arises naturally when
you look at plants they have the same
recursive structure to them the trunk of
a tree branches off into branches which
in turn branch off into smaller branches
etc etc and you can see that self
and all sorts of plans where the smaller
bits look like shrunken versions of the
entire thing so now how to implement
this there's two major parts that you
need to implement first is the
construction of the sentence which is
the result of applying as many rules as
you can and the second part is given a
sentence
ie a set of symbols translating those
symbols into a geometric shape
in other words drawing it so let's
tackle the first part constructing the
sentence and you'll be pleased to know
that this is incredibly simple in the
code this is done through the function
apply rules and you can see from the
code here that all it does is it starts
with the axiom it uses this helper
function apply rules to sentence which
takes a sentence applies all the rules
and returns a new sentence looking in
apply rules to sentence what this does
is it starts by looping over every
character in the sentence and then for
that character it looks for rules it
applies to that character it uses this
helper here a fine matching rule to find
the rules it applies and if it does we
add those new symbols to the new
sentence otherwise we just put back the
old one now to draw this we look at the
render function what we do here is get
the canvas and clear it out then we set
an initial transform and this is just so
that when we draw all the operations
take place from the middle of the canvas
at the bottom of the screen because
these are plants we want them to grow up
so quick sidenote the symbols that we're
using in these examples now like F plus
+ bracket whatever these look kind of
confusing but we use these for
historical reasons originally a lot of
these refer to the commands for the
turtle graphics library which dates back
to 1967 we don't have to do that anymore
and I ditch them in more complex
examples for now if we use them as is we
get to use the original examples that
were given by Lyndon Mayer so let's just
use them anyway back to the code so all
we do is iterate the list of symbols and
sequence the symbols we support for now
our F which means draw a line plus and
minus which just means turn a little bit
to the left or a little bit to the right
and the square brackets which are just a
way of managing the state of the
transform
we push or pop the state depending on
whether or not receive the opening or
closing bracket so as he loop over the
list of symbols and draw them we end up
getting tree-like structures in the UI
here I can play with the number of
iterations that is the number of times I
loop over the sentence applying the
rules and this really helps to see the
self similarity with the very first
preset in no iteration so you can see
the basic tree structure but if I drag
this over by wooden suddenly the
complexity of the tree jumps up a lot
but you can see that it's just the same
tree pasted again over and over again
just smaller take a look at this new
branch on the right and you can see that
it's just a smaller version of the tree
from the first iteration
that's that self similarity I'm talking
about I've also added a bunch of presets
most of these are taken straight from
the original book by Lyndon Mayer the
algorithmic beauty of plants which is
free online if you want to take a look
you can just find it on google or it's
in the description below
I also added leaves they're just drawn
right at the end of segments that don't
branch off and you can play with the
color or the shape as I'm here to make
them longer or fatter I've also added a
few other knobs and dials for you to
play with so you can fit around the
length and width of segments of the
plants there's also this angle parameter
when playing with this can change the
look for the plants pretty dramatically
so you can see that I can kind of make a
weed out of a tree just by making a
little more yellowish and tidying it up
by decreasing the angle you'll also
notice that I have a complex HTML and in
experimental HTML and we've been looking
at the basic HTML but if you're
interested let's take a look at the more
complicated versions in the more complex
version we implement some slightly more
advanced rules in this version we allow
some variation on all the parameters and
that's controlled by this variability
parameter up here which is in essence a
randomness parameter so as I increase
the randomness the angles the lengths
and sizes of things they can all get
increasingly random we've also added a
stochastic grammar meaning that it's
possible for more than one rule to match
at a time with a given probability and
that means that it adds a lot more
randomness to the growth since branches
may or may not appear depending
which version you get and as I change
the random seed lots of variations of
the same tree appear here and finally I
have an experimental version that adds
and tracks the age of every component so
you get a more natural growth animation
which just kind of looks neat anyway
that's as far as we're gonna go today
hopefully you enjoyed this and if you
want to see more content like it hit
subscribe and like the video
Cheers